Nadie ha estudiado sistemáticamente
para saber qué moléculas son verdaderamente feromonas.
Solo han investigado algunas,
y todos estos experimentos se basan en ellas,
pero no hay ninguna evidencia confiable en absoluto.
Eso no quiere decir
que el olor no sea importante para la gente.
Lo es, y algunas personas son verdaderos entusiastas,
y uno de ellos fue Napoleón.
Tal vez recordarán,
que estando fuera preparándose para la guerra,
le escribió a su amante, la emperatriz Josefina,
diciendo: "No te bañes. Regreso a casa".
(Risas)
No quería que ella perdiera su fragancia
mientras él regresaba.
Al día de hoy, encontrarán sitios web
que ofrecen esto como gran excentricidad.
Aunque, al mismo tiempo,
gastamos casi la misma cantidad de dinero
para quitarnos los olores
y para ponérnoslos otra vez en perfumes,
y los perfumes son un negocio de miles de millones de dólares.
Así que lo que haré en el resto de esta charla
es decirles qué son realmente las feromonas,
decirles por qué suponemos
que los humanos tienen feromonas,
contarles algunas de las confusiones entorno a las feromonas,
y, finalmente, quisiera terminar con
una vía prometedora que nos muestra
el camino que deberíamos de seguir.
Los antiguos griegos sabían
que los perros se enviaban señales invisibles unos a otros.
Una hembra en celo
enviaba una señal invisible a los perros
en kilómetros a la redonda,
y no era un sonido, era un olor.
Podían tomar el olor de la hembra,
y los perros perseguían el trapo.
Pero el problema para todos
quienes podían ver este efecto
era que no podían identificar las moléculas.
No podían demostrar que era químico.
La razón de eso, por supuesto,
es que cada uno de estos animales
produce cantidades pequeñas,
y en el caso del perro,
los perros machos pueden olerlo, pero nosotros no.
Y fue hasta 1959 que un equipo alemán,
después de pasar 20 años en la búsqueda de estas moléculas,
descubrió e identificó a la primera feromona,
la feromona sexual de la polilla de la seda.
Fue una elección increíble de Adolf Butenandt y su equipo,
porque necesitó medio millón de polillas
para conseguir suficiente material para el análisis químico.
Pero él creó el modelo
de cómo llevar a cabo el análisis de las feromonas.
Básicamente lo hizo de forma sistemática,
demostrando que solo la molécula en cuestión
era la que estimulaba a los machos,
no todas las demás.
La analizó cuidadosamente.
Sintetizó la molécula,
y luego probó la molécula sintetizada en los machos
y consiguió que estos respondieran demostrando que era,
en efecto, esa molécula.
Eso cierra el círculo.
Es algo que nunca se ha hecho con humanos,
nada sistemático, ninguna demostración real.
Con ese nuevo concepto,
necesitábamos una nueva palabra,
que fue la palabra "feromona",
y básicamente, es "emoción transmitida",
transmitida entre individuos,
y desde 1959, se han encontrado feromonas
en todo el reino animal,
tanto en machos como en hembras.
Igualmente aplica bajo el agua
para peces y langostas.
Y en casi todos los mamíferos,
se ha identificado una feromona,
al igual que en un enorme número de insectos.
Así que, sabemos que las feromonas existen
en todo el reino animal.
Pero ¿qué pasa con los seres humanos?
Bueno, lo primero,
es que somos mamíferos,
y los mamíferos son olorosos.
Cualquier dueño de un perro puede decir
que tanto nosotros como ellos olemos.
Pero la verdadera razón por la que podríamos pensar
que los seres humanos tienen feromonas
es debido al cambio que ocurre a medida que crecemos.
El olor en la habitación de un adolescente
es muy diferente
al olor en la habitación de un niño pequeño.
¿Qué ha cambiado? Por supuesto, es la pubertad.
Junto con el vello púbico
y el vello en las axilas,
nuevas glándulas comienzan a secretar en esos lugares,
y eso es lo que ocasiona el cambio en el olor.
Si fuéramos otro tipo de mamífero,
u otro tipo de animal,
diríamos,
"Debe tener algo que ver con las feromonas"
y empezaríamos a buscar adecuadamente.
Pero hay algunos problemas, y es por eso,
que pienso que, la gente no ha buscado
las feromonas de manera eficaz en los humanos.
Efectivamente, hay problemas.
Y el primero de ellos
quizás es sorprendente.
Es cuestión de cultura.
Las polillas no entienden mucho
sobre lo que es bueno para oler, pero los humanos sí lo hacen,
y hasta la edad de casi 4 años,
cualquier olor, no importa cuán rancio sea,
es simplemente interesante.
Y entiendo que el principal papel de los padres
es evitar que los niños metan los dedos en el popó,
ya que siempre es algo bueno de oler.
Pero gradualmente aprendemos lo que no es bueno,
y una de las cosas que aprendemos
al mismo tiempo
es lo que es bueno.
El queso detrás de mí
es británico, una delicadeza inglesa.
Es un Stilton azul maduro.
Este gusto es incomprensible para personas de otros países.
Cada cultura tiene su propia comida especial
y su especialidad nacional.
Si vinieran de Islandia,
su platillo nacional
sería tiburón podrido.
Todos estos son gustos adquiridos,
pero forman casi un signo de identidad.
Eres parte del grupo.
En segundo lugar esta el sentido del olfato.
Cada uno de nosotros tiene un mundo de olores único,
en el sentido de que cuando olemos,
cada uno huele un mundo completamente diferente.
El olfato fue el más difícil
de los sentidos de descifrar,
y el Premio Nobel otorgado a
Richard Axel y Linda Buck
en 2004, fue por descubrir
cómo funciona el sentido del olfato.
Es verdaderamente difícil,
pero en esencia, los nervios del cerebro
se dirigen a la nariz
y sobre estos nervios expuestos
al aire exterior se encuentran los receptores,
y las moléculas de olor que entran con la inhalación
interactúan con estos receptores,
y si se unen, envían una señal al nervio
que regresa hacia el cerebro.
No solo tenemos un tipo de receptor.
Si eres un ser humano, tienes cerca de 400
diferentes tipos de receptores,
y el cerebro sabe lo que estás oliendo
debido a la combinación de receptores
y a las células nerviosas que estos activan,
mandando mensajes hacia el cerebro
de forma combinatoria.
Pero es un poco más complicado,
porque cada uno de esos 400
viene en diversas variantes,
y dependiendo de la variante que tengan,
pueden oler el cilantro, esa hierba,
ya sea como algo delicioso y sabroso
o les puede oler a jabón.
Así cada uno de nosotros tiene un mundo individual de olores,
y eso lo complica todo
al estudiar el olfato.
Realmente deberíamos hablar de las axilas,
y debo decir que tengo particularmente unas muy buenas.
No voy a mostrárselas,
pero este es el lugar en el que la mayoría de las personas
ha buscado las feromonas.
Hay una buena razón,
que es, que los grandes simios tienen las axilas
como su característica única.
Los otros primates tienen glándulas de olor
en otras partes del cuerpo.
Los grandes simios tienen estas axilas
llenas de glándulas secretoras
produciendo olores todo el tiempo,
un enorme número de moléculas.
Cuando son secretadas desde las glándulas,
las moléculas son inodoras.
No tienen ningún olor,
y es solo por las maravillosas bacterias
que crecen en esta selva de pelo,
que se producen los olores
que conocemos y amamos.
Y si de paso, quieren reducir
la cantidad de olor,
depilen sus axilas
es una forma muy efectiva de reducir
el hábitat de las bacterias,
y descubrirán que permanecen sin tanto olor
por mucho más tiempo.
Pero, aunque nos hemos enfocado en las axilas,
creo que es en parte porque es el lugar
menos vergonzoso para pedir muestras de la gente.
En realidad, hay otra razón por la que tal vez
no busquemos ahí una feromona sexual universal,
y es porque el 20 % de la población mundial
no tiene las axilas olorosas como las mías.
Y son las personas procedentes de China, Japón,
Corea y otras partes del noreste de Asia.
Simplemente no segregan los precursores inodoros
que las bacterias aman usar para producir los olores
que de manera etnocéntrica siempre pensamos
que es una característica de las axilas.
Por lo tanto, no aplica al 20 % del mundo.
Entonces, ¿qué debemos hacer
en nuestra búsqueda de las feromonas humanas?
Estoy convencido de que las tenemos.
Somos mamíferos, y como cualquier otro mamífero,
probablemente las tenemos.
Pero lo que creo que debemos hacer
es regresar al principio,
y, básicamente, buscar en todo el cuerpo.
No importa qué tan vergonzoso sea,
tenemos que buscar e ir por primera vez
a donde nadie se ha atrevido
Va a ser difícil,
va a ser vergonzoso, pero tenemos que buscar.
También necesitamos volver a las ideas
que usó Butenandt cuando estudió a la polilla de la seda.
Necesitamos regresar y examinar sistemáticamente
todas las moléculas que se están produciendo,
e identificar las que están realmente involucradas.
No es suficiente simplemente con tomar un par
y decir: "Son estas".
Tenemos que demostrar
que realmente tienen los efectos que afirmamos.
Hay un equipo que me tiene realmente impresionado.
Están en Francia, y su éxito anterior
fue la identificación de la feromona mamaria del conejo.
Tienen su atención ahora
en los bebés humanos y en las madres.
Este es un bebé tomando leche
del pecho de su madre.
Su pezón está completamente escondido
por la cabeza del bebé,
pero lo que notarán es una gotita blanca
señalada por una flecha,
y es la secreción de las glándulas areolares.
Todos las tenemos, hombres y mujeres,
son las pequeñas protuberancias alrededor del pezón,
y si eres una mujer amamantando,
estas comienzan a secretar.
Es una secreción muy interesante.
Lo qué Benoist Schaal y su equipo desarrollaron
fue una prueba sencilla para investigar
el efecto de esta secreción,
una simple prueba biológica.
Este es un bebé durmiendo,
y bajo su nariz, pusimos una varilla de vidrio limpio.
El bebé permanece dormido,
sin mostrar ningún interés en absoluto.
Pero si vamos con cualquier madre
que este secretando de las glándulas areolares,
no se trata de reconocer,
puede ser de cualquier madre,
si tomamos la secreción
y la ponemos debajo de la nariz del bebé,
obtenemos una reacción muy diferente.
Es la reacción de un conocedor del placer,
abre su boca,
saca la lengua
y comienza a succionar.
Ya que viene de cualquier madre,
podría en verdad ser una feromona.
No se trata de reconocimiento individual.
Cualquier madre lo podría hacer.
¿Por qué es importante,
aparte de ser muy interesante?
Es porque las mujeres varían
en el número de las glándulas areolares que tienen,
y hay una correlación entre la facilidad
con la que los bebés comienzan a succionar
y el número de glándulas areolares que tienen.
Parece que mientras más secreciones tiene,
es probable que el bebe comience a succionar más rápidamente.
Si eres un mamífero,
el momento más peligroso en la vida
son las primeras horas después de nacer.
Es necesario esa primera leche,
y si no la consigues, no sobrevivirás.
Morirás.
Debido a que a muchos bebés les resulta difícil
tomar esa primera comida,
porque no reciben el estímulo adecuado,
si pudiéramos identificar cuál era esa molécula,
y el equipo francés está siendo muy cuidadoso,
pero si pudiéramos identificar la molécula,
sintetizarla, entonces significaría que los bebés prematuros
tendrían más posibilidades de amamantarse,
y cada bebé tendría una mayor oportunidad
de sobrevivir.
Lo que quiero decir es que este es un ejemplo
de cómo un enfoque sistemático, realmente científico,
nos puede mostrar una comprensión real
de las feromonas.
Puede haber todo tipo de intervenciones médicas.
Podría haber muchas cosas
que los humanos están haciendo con las feromonas
que simplemente no sabemos.
Lo que debemos recordar es que las feromonas
no solo tienen que ver con el sexo.
Se relacionan con muchas más cosas
en la vida de los mamíferos.
Así que adelante y a buscar más.
Hay mucho que encontrar.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)